hey guys what's up my name is curly
blasquez and I'm Christian Zamora and
we're here at the AMAs red carpet as you
know J Lo's hosting the AMAs this year
so we're gonna make celebrities take a
which JLo song are you quiz made by are
you willing to take it all right we
gotta unlock it don't remember that
password choose a stunning red carpet
look oh my god I was talking about this
one today I bet I like this one oh wow
how could I see his hair is really cool
yeah I'm gonna do that choose a chain
look like all the wedding planner is so
good wait no actually for cooker made in
Manhattan that one was really scary boy
next door lights change
I was just where that's gonna be
triggered the whole time because he was
so hot Selena Selena forever
choose a JLo X Oh Marc Anthony no don't
pick that one just gonna pick whatever
you want
I choose JLo my favorite puffy you don't
have to just not at all
choosing Marc this sexier I just choose
Jail oh my god get it right there's no
get right I don't have an extended bath
with the whole line I've only known you
for like two minutes but I'd say you're
Jenny from the block
all right I'm Franny from the block
get it